foreign
about a month ago we once again first an
exclusive reported to you guys at
Babylon 5 was in fact not dead and the
discussions at Warner Brothers were
still ongoing well today JMS on Twitter
has confirmed that that he is still
waiting for a phone call from the
executives and until that phone call
happens one way or another Babylon 5 is
still very much on track to get made
today I am going to be talking live with
Scott from the podcast
gray17 a Babylon 5 podcast and we're
going to be talking everything about the
reimagining of Babylon 5 what we can
expect what we hope for and any other
little insights we can come up with see
you then